love to introduce to you now our
leadership that is here visiting us here
in RGV Mr secretary from Homeland
Security thank you sir
thank you very much Chief Chavez
the situation at the border is a very
serious one a very challenging one and a
very difficult one
every single day and every single night
day in and day out 24 hours a day seven
days a week the United States border
patrol agents are keeping our borders
secure they are an extraordinary
Workforce and I am and this country is
incredibly grateful for them
the situation is indeed very difficult I
was in McCallum yesterday in McAllen
yesterday and I'm in Brownsville today
and what the purpose of my trip is to
review our operations and to see our
planning for the end of title 42 in
action I met with border patrol agents I
have met with our extraordinary office
of field operations Personnel of U.S
Customs and Border Protection I met with
at Port Isabel with our Immigration and
Customs Enforcement personnel with local
community leaders law enforcement
Leaders with non-profit organizations as
well as Chief Chavez said this requires
a community response to a challenge to
our communities and that is indeed what
we are bringing a community response it
is no different across the entire region
across the entire Western Hemisphere
this is a regional lunch that requires
Regional Solutions it is not unique to
the southern border of the United States
and I've spoken about this before and
therefore
three weeks ago I was in Panama to meet
with our Panamanian and Colombian
partners and we agreed to Surge
enforcement operations to prevent
individuals from entering the very
dangerous and treacherous Darien at the
hands of Ruthless Smugglers
earlier this week the president's
Homeland Security adviser met with the
president of Mexico and agreed upon an
enforcement surge in the south of Mexico
to prevent individuals from being
exploited by Smugglers as those
vulnerable individuals are misinformed
by the Smugglers and brought to the
southern border only to be returned a
regional challenge requires a regional
solution let me give you a brief
overview of our approach as we indicated
last week
we are building lawful Pathways that
will provide a safe and orderly way for
individuals who qualify for Relief under
United States law to reach the United
States safely
we are building on the success of our
parole processes that we announced on
January 5th for the Cubans Haitians
nicaraguans and Venezuelans we saw a 95
drop in the number of Encounters of
those individuals at our Southern border
because we built lawful Pathways for
them to access and that is the model
that we are building upon last Thursday
Secretary of State Tony blinken and I
announced the development of regional
processing centers in different parts of
South and Central America
to enable individuals to access lawful
Pathways from those Regional processing
centers whether they qualify for Refugee
processing whether they qualify for our
existing and expanding family
reunification programs whether they
present acute vulnerabilities that may
qualify them for humanitarian parole on
a case-by-case basis we are reaching the
people where they are it is not only our
security obligation it is our
humanitarian responsibility to cut the
Smugglers out and that is indeed what we
are doing we are building Pathways at
the same time
at the same time we will deliver
consequences for individuals who arrive
at our Southern border irregularly that
is our commitment and Our obligation as
a way of cutting the Smugglers out and
taking care of the safety and needs of
individuals who qualify for relief
in a post title 42 environment we will
be using our expedited removal
authorities under title eight of the
United States code that allows us to
remove individuals very quickly we will
by May 11th finalize the rule that we
published in a proposed format that
provides that individuals who do not
access are lawful Pathways will be
presumed to be ineligible for Asylum and
will have a higher burden of proof to
overcome that presumption of
ineligibility we are building lawful
Pathways and we are delivering
consequences for those who do not use
those meaningfully accessible Pathways
the message is very clear we are coming
with the relief that our laws provide to
the individuals in need the border is
not open it has not been opened and it
will not be open subsequent to May 11th
and the Smugglers who exploit vulnerable
migrants are spreading misinformation
they are spreading false information
lies in a way to lure vulnerable people
to the southern border and those
individuals will only be returned to the
to the individuals themselves who are
thinking of migrating
do not believe the Smugglers
please access the official government
Publications please access the the
official government information on the
Department of Homeland Security website
for accurate information because you are
being deceived and you are risking your
lives and your life savings only to meet
a consequence that you do not expect at
our Southern border
to meet our objectives we have been and
continue to Surge Resources Personnel
Transportation capabilities airplanes to
effect a greater number of removals
every week additional facilities the
remarkable facility that the United
States border patrol set up here in
collaboration with the community of
Brownsville this was set up in just 72
hours we are surging resources earlier
today we also announced the distribution
of additional funds to border
communities non-profit organizations and
several interior cities to meet their
needs in their partnership with us to
address the situation at our border and
to address the humanitarian needs of
migrants we distributed approximately
330 million more dollars today for the
benefit of those organizations we have a
plan
we are executing on that plan I have
come to McAllen and Brownsville to see
firsthand that plan in action
fundamentally however fundamentally we
are working within a broken immigration
system that for decades has been in dire
need of Reform that is a fact about
which everyone agrees and we urge
Congress to fix our broken immigration
system and until then we will do
everything that we can within our
authorities to provide an orderly and
safe pathway for individuals who qualify
for Relief under the laws of the United
States of America thank you and with
that I will turn it over to Deputy
Commissioner Kari Huffman of Customs and
Border Protection
uh thank you secretary first off I'd
like to say I'm very glad to be here
along with the secretary Chief Chavez
Chief Ortiz and the rest of the CBP team
we are facing a very very challenging
time leaders show what's important by
where they spend their time and the fact
that the secretary has spent so much
time in this area recognizes the fact
this is a priority for him as a priority
for our government to do everything we
can we are facing very very challenging
times there's no question about that
and we have been preparing for these
challenging times for quite some time
and we're ready there's no better team
to face this than the CBP team which is
a a good example of that of our
preparations the ability for this for
the RGB sector to set up this this
process in three short days it's just
kind of builds upon the lessons we've
learned and how our preparation we've
done that make us ready to take on this
situation we're searching resources
quickly all across the border different
places that we needed we've increased
our capacity by third a third over the
last 24 months to help us be prepared
for this we're working hard to do this
we're focused on getting as many agents
back on the line we have been we've been
hiring for the last year or so
contractors and non-uniform Personnel to
do jobs that long that border collating
is going to do to get them back on the
line so it's very important to do that
to follow up on what the commissioner
said on May 11th it will still be
unlawful into this country illegally
with the we will be relying Upon Our
decades-old title Aid processes we've
used time and time again in the past to
enforce the law and to protect the
border that coupled with increasing in
criminal prosecutions will allow for the
rule of law to Prevail on our border and
that's our goal and that's your
challenges we're facing but I want to
spend a few minutes here to talk about
the CBP team and tell you exactly how
proud I am on the work they've done and
continue to do for the last year and a
half I've traveled this country and I'm
uh this many different stations many
different locations talking to our
Workforce to better understand their
challenges they're facing and I can tell
you I'm sure the secretary Chief Ortiz
and chief Choppers agree we couldn't be
more prouder than the work they do in
the communities and the community work
this which is further identified in the
risk they takes and I couldn't uh close
out making one moment about the work of
our recently with the youth border
patrol Vortec team and how they raised
up in the community to help arrest that
a a wanted murder had been on the run
for several days to help keep that
Community safe that's the quality of the
Personnel you have working this border
situation that's the quality of the
people in your community and I couldn't
be more proud of them with that I'm
going to turn around G4 D's to give more
operational details about what's going
on with our preparations chief
good afternoon and thank you Deputy
Commissioner Mr secretary for coming
down here to see firsthand the great
work that's uh unfolding uh in Rio
Grande Valley and South Texas and then
Chief Chavez for your leadership I will
tell you that a couple weeks ago
secretary asked me where do we need to
go first Chief and I said before May
11th when you go to South Texas we knew
that we were going to see some increases
down here and that has transpired over
the last two weeks Brownsville has
traditionally been a slower area for us
in South Texas and what we've seen
that's unfolded here just south of us is
migrant populations for Venezuela have
crossed 24 hours a day the chief
responded with medical assets and
resources we've asked for some support
from other agencies we've got our Texas
Department of Public Safety Personnel
working side by side with by our board
for agents and we have our ofo partners
and then we have our state and local
Partners once again this is a team
effort we're continuing to move these
migrants into our processing facilities
as quickly as we possibly can we have
tremendous capacity here in South Texas
we have had that for about six or seven
years and we're going to continue to
leverage that to the best of our ability
as the secretary mentioned we're going
to balance that against our border
security Mission set we want to keep as
many border patrol agents out on those
front lines allow our processing
coordinators our volunteers our DOD
Personnel the 1500 DOD Personnel are
going to help us on those admin
functions so we can get agents back out
on patrol ultimately our goal is to keep
these communities safe and make sure
that our agents are safe when they're
out there performing their duties each
and every day so Mr secretary thank you
for your continued support of the Border
Patrol and we appreciate the fact that
you guys continue to cover this story
because it is an important story thank
you
can you explain why you've seen this big
surge in the last couple weeks sorry
thank you oh sorry can you explain why
you've seen this big surge in the last
couple weeks and if you're seeing this
big of a surge ahead of May 11th or May
12th
what do you expecting come May 12th
so um the the surge of the past couple
weeks is really focused on one
particular demographic we've seen an
increase in the number of Venezuelan
Nationals coming to our border it's very
difficult to identify the cause you know
the the
um the challenge of migration is in one
aspect it's dynamism it is a very
complex phenomenon uh we saw the the
tragic fire in the city of Juarez in in
Mexico and the impact domestically
within Mexico and since then we saw over
the past two weeks a significant surge
of Venezuelans we are we have reached an
agreement uh with the government of
Mexico to address that surgeon we're
going to see the results of that
agreement very shortly
and if so how prepared are you for a
search in terms of processing people so
just to make sure that everybody heard
the um the question do we expect a a
surgeon if so how prepared are we so for
as as the commissioner uh mentioned is
commissioner Huffman mentioned we've
been preparing for well over a year it
was in September of 2021 when we first
developed a six pillar plan uh to
address uh the end of title 42 we
updated that uh throughout uh the the
calendar year 2022. so we've been
preparing for quite some time and we are
ready what we are expecting is indeed a
surge
um and what we are doing is planning for
different levels of research that is
what we do we plan for different
scenarios so we are ready to address
them and we are indeed ready to address
them
sorry uh Mr secretary thank you so much
for taking my question can you just talk
a little bit about some of the things
that you've seen on the ground some of
the concerns that you're hearing
um and given that we're in a region
that's already seeing thousands of
encounters a day how confident are you
that the measures that you've put in
place are going to work
I think that there is no question that
this is going to be extremely
challenging I do not want to understate
the severity of the challenge that we
expect to encounter uh the the border is
a very as I said at the very outset it
is a difficult situation it requires not
only a community of action on this side
of the Border but it requires a
community of action south of our border
not only with our Mexican Partners but
with other countries throughout the
region and indeed we have an
international approach to an
international uh challenge what I've
seen on the ground in my visit to
McAllen and to Brownsville is no
different than what I've seen in my more
than 15 prior trips to the Border as the
Secretary of Homeland Security I have
seen an extraordinary Workforce in green
uniform in the United States border
patrol in blue youth uniform in the
office of field operations of U.S
customs and order protection across the
expanse of the Department of Homeland
Security and quite frankly across the
expanse of this entire Administration
this Administration addresses challenges
as one team in an all of government
approach
for chief Ortiz thank you for taking my
question uh back in March in McAllen you
told Republican lawmakers that the U.S
does not have an operational control of
the Southern border do you still stand
by that statement and if so what is um
do you need to gain control of the
Border yeah so the question that was
posed during my hearing was the uh
Congressional legislative definition of
operational control where nobody crosses
the Border I've been doing this job for
32 years we've never had operational
control have we had various levels of
control yeah most certainly even while I
was the active Chief or deputy chief
here for five and a half years this side
of Rio Grande Valley was very secure but
out on my West Side we had surges quite
often in Rio Grande City Star County and
Hidalgo County and that plays out across
the entire stretch of the 2000 miles
border that we share with Mexico and so
I have some sectors that I have greater
levels of confidence in just because the
flow isn't what it is but this morning
Chief Chavez his team apprehended 2300
people in the sector and so that
requires an awful lot of capacity and
certainly poses some different
significant challenges for us so I stick
by my comments that I made during the
hearing but we've never had that
and the plans that are in place
obviously for majority Venezuelan
migrants that was expanded to Haitian
Cuban and Nicaraguan migrants why isn't
that policy being enforced right now
many of the migrants I'm meeting along
the streets of Brownsville are swimming
in between the ports of Entry as you
have mentioned if that happens are
supposed to be returned they're not
being returned and they're single adults
without family here why is that
happening so um I think you are actually
mistaken because the parole process for
Cubans Haitians nicaraguans and
Venezuelans that we first announced and
implemented on January 5th is uh
underway and continues to be underway
and we continue if I may if I may it
does and if I may we continue uh to
parole individuals of those four
nationalities when they qualify under
the program that we established and
announced and that requires a sponsor
here in the United States to ensure that
those individuals have Financial
stability and they are able to arrive in
a safe and orderly way that is indeed
underway and we continue and we continue
to expel Cuban's Haitians nicaraguans
and Venezuelans the number of
Venezuelans that we've been able to
expel has actually diminished over the
past two weeks the cause of that is a
very complicated one we've sat down with
the Mexican Government and those
expulsions and of course in a post title
42 environment those removals will
continue and that is why the message is
so important that people vulnerable
people are receiving false information
they are being lied to that if they come
and arrive at our border that they can
stay in the United States that is not
what the law provides that is not the
consequence that we will deliver
I'm sorry good afternoon Mr secretary
you mentioned after May 11 there would
be quote a higher burden of proof that
the migrants would need to show to have
exceptions could you expand upon that
could you also talk about the credible
fear interviews and the processes that
you're going through to expedite these
migrants so many so um the rule is being
finalized and until that rule is indeed
final and published
it is difficult for me to to answer the
question just as a matter of law because
it is not set it is not established
until it is actually final uh and
published but the general concept the
general concept is as follows that
individuals who access the lawful
Pathways that we deliver for them will
be able to come to the United States in
a safe and orderly way those who travel
irregularly in the hands of Smugglers
because I have to repeat again it is a
security and humanitarian imperative
that we cut the Smugglers out
those who arrive irregularly at our
border will be presumed absent some
limited exceptions will be presumed to
be ineligible
for Asylum and they will meet a
rebuttable presumption of ineligibility
to overcome that presumption they will
have to meet a higher threshold of proof
does it you were saying the Smugglers
are leading them to misinformation and
if they come out here illegally if they
cross illegally and they don't meet the
threshold that they will be exposed
that's the message you're sending can
you walk us through what that looks like
is that like a mass deportation
something different than what we've been
seeing so so Griff
um in a when title 42 comes to an end on
May 11th we will use as we have
expressed before our traditional
immigration authorities the ones that we
sought to use earlier when we sought to
end title 42 but were prevented from
doing so uh by a court and title eight
of the United States quote are
traditional immigration authorities
actually deliver a consequence because
when someone is removed when someone
does not qualify for Relief and is
removed from the United States they face
an at least five-year bar
from admission into the United States so
the consequence is going to be more
severe and what we will do what we will
do is remove individuals who do not
qualify for Relief under the standard
that will be set by the rule that we
have will have finalized by May 11th
thank you so much I just have a question
for you Mr secretary and a quick one for
chief Ortiz um Mr secretary we've heard
from Mayors here in the Rio Grande
Valley and across Texas that they're
concerned they're not equipped to handle
the number of migrants entering their
streets DHS just allocated as you
mentioned 300 million to ngos and Border
communities but does the federal
government have a role in standing up
housing and Medical Care especially when
hospitals ngos and churches are at
capacity and migrants are sleeping on
their sidewalks and just quickly to
Chief Ortiz can you explain
geographically where troops will be
located which sectors are they staying
so Nicole we are working very very
closely with City and local officials as
I have expressed earlier we are working
with non-profit organizations this
requires a community response and we are
providing funding through our emergency
food and shelter program Congress
allocated 800 million dollars to this
program last year we only had 150
million dollars we have allocated a
great number of those funds already to
Resource the communities to address the
needs that you express there are
approximately 363 million dollars left
to distribute we will do that through
the new shelter and Services Program the
community challenges require a community
response and we are working holistically
with communities across the border to
address this challenge
and then with respect to the dod
Personnel So currently we have 2500 DOD
Personnel supporting the CBP border
patrol Mission and they're housed and
stationed across the Southwest border
the additional 1500 Personnel that are
going to be allocated over the next few
weeks will be based in El Paso but what
that will allow me to do is resources
that I've been dedicating to El Paso
because it has been a much busier place
over the last six months I'm going to be
able to reallocate those to some of the
other sectors that require some
additional capacity so we're going to be
able to balance that out we've got a
plan we've been working with our
partners with DOD and we appreciate
their support thank you everybody I want
to say something more about that if I
may Chief Ortiz and Nicole
um the deployment of Department of
Defense Personnel is nothing new
um since 2006 every single year since
2006 U.S Customs and Border Protection
and specifically the United States
border patrol has relied upon additional
resources from the Department of Defense
this
year is the first year thanks to
President Biden budget this is the first
this is the first year since 2011 that
we have been able to dedicate 300 new
border patrol agents to the United
States border patrol the president's
fiscal year 2024 budget asks for an
additional 350 border patrol agents we
are plusing up the United States border
patrol for the first time in more than a
decade and we are committed to
continuing to do so do so resources are
vital to the effort that we have
underway the challenges will be
significant the plans we have pla in
place are tailored to meet those
challenges we have the greatest
Workforce in the world to fulfill our
mission and we will do so and I'm so
incredibly proud to support them thank
you all for being here
everyone